this is an article that caught my
attention
nadia bacody
um she as far as i know is a
sex-positive journalist
that's what i was told
sex red flags women shouldn't ignore so
i was like oh this is interesting we're
going to go through some of them and
then i'm going to talk to you about
what's wrong with this article
did you notice maybe the picture can
tell you a little bit about what's wrong
with the article but we'll get to that
all right tyler's laughing so here's
some of the worst offenders according to
nadia and tyler if you wouldn't mind
maybe you could on the side i don't know
if you could do that pull up a little
bio of nadia i didn't that's the one
thing i didn't print
so skipping she talks about this is when
a partner approaches sex like a netflix
series
and they skip to the highlights so in
other words they don't do the foreplay
they're not interested in the foreplay
they ignore it they have no
consideration for the arousal stage we
know men and women are different in this
respect women need some time to get from
point a to point z right so yes clearly
if a guy is skipping
the foreplay what that usually means is
he's not very good in bed i hate to say
it and he doesn't know how to do it so
he's like well i'm just gonna i don't
know i'm just gonna skip that or he
doesn't care about you right doesn't
care about you maybe he's there for one
night stan
maybe he's there to be in and out and
he's not looking to make you happy he's
looking to make himself happy because
it's not a partnership he's not that
invested in you that's why that happens
okay to selling sellers will try to sell
you on the idea of having sex without a
condom after you've already insisted on
using one yeah obviously that's bad
that's bad it's gross it's disgusting we
talked about the roll of tamasi clip in
the beginning where the girls are like
[Music]
i'll ask immediately though already i
can't bite my tongue why
nadia
why are women finding themselves in
these situations
i've never encountered either of these
situations ask yourself that let it
ruminate in your mind while we read the
rest pump and dump this is one of my
favorites
well labeled i'm not gonna lie
this is when it's casual sex and a guy
comes in sleeps with you
implication is that it's largely a guy
doing these behaviors comes in and then
you have sex and they leave right
they're not cuddling with you
they're not hanging out asking and
checking in to see how you're doing and
this is what she says a good partner
even a casual one will check in after
sex to see how you're feeling and sure
you're comfortable and may also stay to
converse for a while not if it's a
one-night stand honey that's why it's
called a one-night stand they don't care
about you so why are you doing it
i'll get back to that and the last one
is king in it
oh god now famously resurface interview
from 2015 dj khalid controversially
revealed he doesn't perform oral sex on
his wife because there are different
rules for men i'm pretty sure marin over
fresh and fit shares a similar opinion
i've seen video if i'm pretty sure it's
myron that says something like that a
woman should praise the man the king
yeah this is this is some horseshit
ladies you get into a relationship with
a guy and he there's a separate set of
rules for him sexually he wants you to
pleasure him but he's not willing to
pleasure you he doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you get up leave done okay this is
not a monarchy those out there guys are
the key it's not a monarchy honey it's a
republic that [ __ ] is over we fought
wars to get rid of that [ __ ] just saying
okay
so let's just go back though because you
know i like to put responsibility on the
guys when it's when it's necessary and
on the ladies so i looked at this and i
said to myself hmm
skipping selling kinging it pumping i
never encountered any of these things in
my life do you know why
well i will tell you because i didn't
have any one night stands
because everybody that i slept with i
was in deep like or love with
because there was a pre-existing
relationship because i had set those
standards because i had self-respect and
i wasn't going to allow myself to allow
someone else into my body if i was
worried about these things so if you
find yourself in these situations
the number one red flag here is you
you
you have a problem you are inviting
people into your space and then have
like unrealistic expectations of how
they should behave right
you're not doing the proper research
you're being too flippant with your
sexuality you're not respecting yourself
you're expecting some guy that's there
for a one-night stand in casual sex to
want to converse with you afterward
that's not why he's there if you want
that conversation you got gotta get into
a relationship you gotta get involved
with somebody who really cares about you
you can't have these expectations of
one-night stands that don't make any
sense they're not there for that they're
there for casual sex they don't care
about you they're telling you straight
up
right
they're there to sleep with you end of
story and they as far as they understand
it may think you're just there to sleep
with them
so if you want all of these attributes
and these positive things that come from
a relationship which is a guy that's
gonna care about satisfying you and not
say oh i'm here to king it if you want
someone who's gonna hold you afterward
and make you feel like that was a
connecting moment if you want someone
who's gonna listen to how you feel about
condom use and who's gonna care that
they don't want you to walk away being
worried about pregnancy if you're with
if you want all of this concern
attributed to the experience then be
with someone who cares about you and is
concerned about you and that is not
going to show up in a one-night stand so
i don't know if you've seen these nadia
if this is from personal experience but
i don't know got that picture at the top
of the column
a little salacious all this stuff going
on did you have that bio on nadia by the
way nadia bakodi is a sex columnist
youtuber and media commentator with a
passion for empowering women in their
sexuality relationships and mental
health her instagram bio of course she
has her pronouns she her
she calls herself an angry dyke sex
columnist
her website
is the internet's number one destination
for sex positive people
we should try to get her on
that would be a fantastic conversation
again sex positive there was that girl
that said she was sex positive on the
bachelor katie katie thurston i think
her name was remember the one who showed
up with the vibrator she jumped out of
the car she had a vibrator
and then she became the next
bachelorette i was talking sex positive
sex positive sex positive i i don't
really understand what that means
anymore i really don't does that mean
that women get to be [ __ ] what does
that mean sex positive sex positive does
that mean that you have expectations
about one-night stands that don't make
sense because they're really
expectations you should have within the
context of a real relationship
is this like a reject real relationships
because real relationships aren't cool
and i'm trying to mimic bad male
behavior so i'm going to reject real
relations but then still want all of
those things so what what is going on
here i don't really understand it bottom
line if you find yourself in these
situations number one you're dealing
with [ __ ] men get out
don't sleep with a guy who has a problem
you wanna you're out you're there you
don't need to be walking home with some
gonorrhea or any of that okay you don't
need any of that
so if you're with a guy that's gonna
give you a hard time get get up and say
honey you're not for me i'm sorry i
gotta go
don't don't be getting involved with
that but if you repeatedly are finding
yourself in situations with
douchey men
self-reflect
think about the decisions you're making
why is that happening think about it and
take some ownership you have to take
ownership of your decisions
it can't be like oh i always find myself
in these debacles i don't know how it
must be everyone but me
who does that help no one
and it doesn't help you get out of your
situation because ultimately what needs
to change is you need to make different
decisions that doesn't mean that what
they're doing isn't bad there you can be
surrounded by people who are making bad
decisions but you're still inviting them
into your space ask yourself why ask
yourself why and stop doing it don't
complain and moan and write articles
change the way you're living
set higher standards set the buy bar
higher and people will come who can meet
that bar and all the garbage underneath
won't be at your door because you won't
tolerate it
it's really very simple self-respect is
a very simple concept if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]